[Music]  you get to romance Jane Fonda yes I do  to the best of my ability of his  delightful romantic Jane Parker I can't  compete with younger women what are you  so afraid of Peter Gallagher returns for  more fun on it season four of Grace and  Frankie now streaming on Netflix but  what about returning to a different role  this year marks 15 years since the start  of the OSI really my goodness you're  right that's shocking  or kind of in the the era of revivals  and reboots would you ever go back and  play sandy again  I love sandy : one please you know if it  was Never Say Never  I love sandy : I'd love to play sandy  Cohen again why do you think he'd be 15  years later older wiser twice as funny  and twice as smart still grabbing bagels  how about babies well that's the secret  password into the Cohen house oh I  imagine pretty much where they you know  what I'm talking about  [Music]